في خضم حرب اسرائيليه غير مسبوقه على قطاع
غزه وتصاعد التوتر في المنطقه وفي سياق
تغطيه الجزيره المستمره لهذه الحرب نستضيف
وزير خارجيه الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه السيد حسين امير عبد اللهيان
سيد الوزير مرحبا بكم انتم في جوله
اقليميه مكثفه لمحاوله وقف الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه وخفض التصعيد في
المنطقه ما ابرز النقاط التي تركزون عليها
في هذه المرحله
بسم الله الرحمن الرح بسم الله الرحمن
الرح قبل اي ش اود ان اتقدم بالشر الجزل
على الجهود التي تبذلها قناه الجزيره
وزملائكم في المساعده لاظهار
الحقائق في الميدان
واظهار الجرائم الحارب التي يرتكبها الكان
الصهيوني العنص والقاتل الاطفال همن ادا
احترام به همه
شهدا جنا ارواح شهداء الجرائم الاخه للان
الصهيون غز و به همه زنان و مردان و
جوانان
فلسطي جميع الشباب والرجال والنساء في
فلسطين وخاصه اهالي غزه وابارك لهم بسبب
هذه الروح العاليه من اجل الصمود
والمقاومه ضد
الان الهون
المحتل دستور وحققه قد
حققوا انجازات عظيمه نتيجه الاجراء العفوي
لمقاومه الفلسط
وحماس شاهد ب وما شهدناه هو
نتجه عقود من الزمن ل قل اكثر من
33 الف طفل فلسطيني والاف النساء والرجال
المدنيين في فلسطين وطبعا تطرف وتشدد
نتنياهو
وحكومه نتنياهو المتطرفه
والمتشدد حول نتنياهو خلال الاشهر الماضيه
بطبيعه الحال فان هذه العمليه العفويه
لحماس والتي كان تصميمها واجرائها
وتنفيذها كان من قبل الفلسطينيين انفسهم
فقد دمر
الهيمنه المزيفه للكيان الصهيوني ان
الصهاينه الذين كانوا يدعون بانه
يمتلكون اقوى الجيوش في الشرق الاوسط
الصهاينه الذين كانوا فرحين با اجراءات
واعمال داعش الارهابيه في
وشها اسلام داعش ومنطقتنا والدول الاسلام
مثل سوريا
والعراق قد قامت داعش باضعاف هذه المنطقه
لكن العالم شهد اليوم بانه لا في بعد
العسكري ولا في البعد الامني والسياسي ولا
حتى
الاجتماع لم تب
سمعه
حمان
الهون المحتل للاراضي الفلسط بغض النظر
عن جرائم
الحرب التي ارتكبها الكان الصهيوني ضد
المدن والنساء
والاطفال
اشعب المقاوم والمظلوم في غزه فان هذه
الجرائم الصهيونيه از ارزش
عمل لا تقل
اهم عمل طوان الاقصى العفويه لحركه حماس
في يوم السبت الماضي في الاراضي
المحتله ماه الحق
وطبعه طبعه الحقق ل تلابيب هو كان ما
شاهدناه يوم السبت
و قد اظهر حقيقه وواقع
وجود
دوله اوان الهون
المز خلال زارت منشورها عراق لبنان وفي
هذه المرحله التي كانت لدي الى العراق
ولبنان وسوريا وقطر اولا كانت هذه فرصه
جيده لكي التقي مع المسؤولين السياسيين في
هذه البلدان وايضا قاده المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وايضا
اللبنانيه هدفنا كان هو تبادل وجهات النظر
و بذ الجهود من اجل مساعده الشعب
الفلسطيني
المظلوم ونحن نعتقد بانه جميع جميعنا يجب
ان نسعى من اجل وقف جرائم الحرب التي
يرتكبها الكان الصهيوني ضد المدنيين في
غزه ان اسرائيل بامكان
مقاوم ان
تحارب مقاتل
المقاومه ان المقاومه ايضا في اي لحظه
ترد وتخطط ولها الامكانيات اللازمه من اجل
الحرب الميدانيه مع العسكريين الصهاينه
لكن ان
اسرائيل اختارت ابشع الطرق والاساليب
اسرائيل التي لي ليست بامكانها ان تقوم
باجراء اخر اسرائيل التي طوال ثمانيه ايام
الماضيه حتى لم تستطع
ان
تقت عسكري او سياسي من المقاومه
الفلسطينيه
وحماس
فلجات الى
ابشع طريقه واسلوب
وهو اباده ال سء والاطفال في غزه التقيتم
في بيروت منسق عمليه السلام الاممي في
الشرق الاوسط تور
وينسل هل وجهت رساله عبره الى اسرائيل سيد
الوزير هو كان يحمل رساله الامين العام
للامم المتحده ونحن منذ بدايه
الازمه كان لدينا اتصال مع انتونيو
جوتيريش الامين العام للامم المتحده
السيد جوتش اكد على ان الجهود الم يبذل
الجهود المكثفه من اجل وقف الهجمات ضد
المدنيين
وايضا انا طلبت منه بانه ان يوفر
الامكانيه لمساعده ارسال لمساعدتنا في
ارسال المساعدات الانسانيه الى غزه منها
مياه الشرب
وطعام
والادويه وطبعا الامين العام
وايضا مسؤول الصليب الاحمر الدولي وعدونا
بانه ان يكون لديهم هذا التعاون مع ايران
وباقي الدول من اجل ارسال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى
غزه ان ممثل الامين العام للامم المتحده
في شؤون الشرق
الاوسط
اد آرامش منقه ج قامه وقف اطلاق النار في
المنطقه
و طرح لنا بعض الافكار من اجل ذلك وطبعا
طلب منا انه ان تكون هناك فرصه وتمنح فرصه
من اجل ان يسعى الامين العام للامم
المتحده من اجل وقف جرائم الحرب للكيان
الصهيوني ضد غزه هذه كانت الرساله الواضحه
للامين العام للامم المتحده وانا في الرد
عليه قلت انه وفقا للمشاورات التي اجريتها
مع قاده المنطقه و
خاصه الوجهات النظر التي كانت لديه التي
كانت قاده المقاومه لديها فان اي اجراء من
اجل وقف هجمات الكيان الصهيوني القاتل
الاطفال ضد المناطق الفلسطينيه وخاصه
غزه اذا لا تصل الى نتيجه بشكل فوري فمن
الممكن اتساع جبهات
الحرب وهذا الامر غير مستبعد وفي كل ساعه
في اي ساعه تزداد احتماليه ذلك وسائل
العلم نقلت منها اكسوس وولا بانكم وجهتهم
رساله لاسرائيل
عبر تور وينسل بان لا تتمادى اسرائيل في
حربها على غزه ما هو هذا التمادي بالنسبه
لكم سيد
الوزير ما اسرائ اولا نحن لا نعترف
باسرائيل لكي نوجه لها رساله
لكن عبر داعم الان الهون ولا سما
امر
نحن ب صراحه
وجهنا هذه
الرساله بكل شفافيه اعلنا
بانه لو لم تكن هناك اجراء وجهود فوريه
لوقف جرائم الحرب لكيان الصهيوني ضد
المدنيين العزل في غزه واذا لا يت
انهاء الحصار الانساني ضد غزه
ف فصائل المقاومه في
المنطقه مستعدون لجميع السيناريوهات ويوم
غد سيكون متاخرا لذلك اليوم المواجهه بين
حزب الله وقوات
الاحتلال تتصاعد في الجبهه الجنوبيه
للبنان وهو ياتي بعيد ساعات من مغادرتكم
بيروت هل هذا التطور بين اسرائيل وحزب
الله ياتي في سياق ما تفضلت به الان بانه
لا يمكن للامور ان تبقى على ما هو عليه في
حال استمرت اسرائيل بما وصفتها
بجرائمها نحن نامل بان الاجراءات السياسيه
الفوريه تحول دون اتساع نطاق الحرب
لكن
فهناك ايه احتماليات في الساعات
المقبله يستطيع ان يتوقع الساعه القادمه
بانه ماذا سيحدث فيها ان المنطقه تعيش في
ظروف حساسه للغايه وان وضع المنطقه وبسبب
استمرار جرائم الحرب للكيان
الصهيوني وبسبب الاجراءات المتشدده
والمتطرفه لنتنياهو وايضا
بسبب اباده النساء والاطفال في الايام
الماضيه في غزه فهو
انبار ممل از مخزن
متفجرات و اي لحظه من الممكن ان
ينفجر هذا هذا المخزن وتخرج الامور عن
سيطره جميع
اللاعب والفاعلين اود ان اؤكد هنا بان
امريكا لا
تستطيع
قرار
مانه رسائل لجميع الاطراف في المنطقه و
توصيهم بضبط النفس لكن للكيان الصهيون و
مث الحرب الاسرائ تقول لهم بانكم انتم
بامان ان ترتب اي جريمه في غزه جهان اسلام
ان العالم الاسلام موم وفصائل
المقاومه وا من
الاطراف لا تطق هذا
الوضع ان الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه
ايضا بالنسبه لاستمرار هذا الوضع لا تبقى
متفرجه بالتاكيد ولكن اريد تعليق منكم على
ما يحدث الان على الحدود الجنوبيه للبنان
بين جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي و وحزب الله
هل هو مرتبط بما تفضلت به وقلت بانه لا
يمكن ان تضل الامور على ما هو عليه في حال
استمرت اسرائيل في حربها على غزه ما در
ديدار باقا خلال لقائ مع سماحه السيد حسن
نصر
اللهه اطلعت على نظ سماحه الس بانه هنا
جمع
السنار قد طرحت على الطاوله وهناك توجد اي
حدوث اي احتماليه في اي لحظه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ترسل حاملات طائرات الى
المنطقه تقول بانها لردع ايران كيف فهمتم
هذه الرساله
الامريكيه ان الامريكيين وكما
اشرت فيوجه رسائل الجميع بانه يجب ان
تلتزموا بضبط النفس
لكن هم
وامريكا لا يوصون هم وعفوا اسرائيل بضبط
النفس اذا لا تتوقف امريكا عن سياستها هذه
ف لا يمكن الاجتناب من توسيع نطاق الحرب
ففي حال حدث ذلك
فاضافة تحولات
منو شراط ر طبعا هو سيعقد الوضع بل فضلا
عن ذلك فهناك احتماليه لاتساع نطاق الحرب
ايضا اكثر من اي وقت مضى ان الحل
السياسي هو
الوقف وقف جرائم
حرب الكيان التي يرتكبها الكيان الصهيوني
ضد المدنيين في غزه ورفع الحصار الانساني
فورا وفي حال استمرار هذه الهجمات
فستكون هناك ظروف معقده في المنطقه
وه سصب الزيت على النار و في اي لحظه من
الممكن ان تخرج الامور عن السيطره ما شكل
هذا التوسع وخروج الامور عن عن السيطره
وما امكانيه ومدى انخراط ايران في هذا سيد
الوزير ابلا اولا نحن نشعر وطبعا انطباعي
هو بانه الطرف الامريكي
يستمر في دعمه الاحادي من الكيان الصهيوني
العنصري ومن خلال ذلك يسعى من اجل
ان تفتح الامكانيه لنتنياهو لكي يقوم باي
شيء يريد ان استمرار هذا
الوضع ف سيغير الوضع بشده لانه ان المنطقه
ليست مكتوفه الايدي ان المنطقه والفاعل
والفاعلين في هذه المنطقه لا يبقون
متفرجين ان الحل السياسي هو وقف الهجمات
ضد المدنيين في
غزه انا ليله امس التقيت
بسماحه سماحه الشيخ اسماعيل هنيه وفي
الدوحه وطبعا قبل ذلك ايضا التقيت بقاده
المقاومه في بيروت وناقشنا معهم الامور
فكل
شيء
كل شيء من الممكن ان يحدث من في طبعا
اتساع نطاق الحرب
واستهداف مثيري الحرب في هذه المنطقه لذلك
قبل ان يتاخر الاوان فيجب ان تتخذ اجراءات
سياسيه او مبادره دوليه
عبر الامين العام للامم المتحده قلت
بانه هناك وقت الان للدبلوماسي وعلينا
الاسراع في وقف الح حرب في حال لم يحصل
هذا ماذا سيترتب عليه سيد الوزير اولا ما
او شبه نحن ليله امس واليوم في المشاورات
التي اجريناها
مع سمو الامر الشخ
تم نخزر
وز
محم رس الوزرا ووزير الخارجيه
القطري فتحدثنا
حول المفه من اجل خروج المطقه من هذا
الوضع القائم
والراح ان استمرار
الحرب خ فهو لا يلحق الاضرار فقط لمدن في
غزه اكد بان
اسرائيل تعيش حاليا في في وضع تعيس وضعيف
بحيث انه حتى لم يستطيعوا ان يستهدفوا
قائدا في قائدا عسكريا في حماس فهم فقد
استهدفوا الاطفال والنساء والمدنيين في
غزه
مقاوم ان المقاومه
مقابل وبشان موضوع الاسراف
لها سلوكا منطقيا انا وخلال لقائي مع
المسؤولين في قطر
وايضا قاده المقاومه
ادرته موضو العسكريين والاسرائيليين
بالنسبه للمقاومه هو خط احمر لكن هم حاليا
يدرسون موضوع
الاسرى غير الاسرى المدن وذا اتيحت الظروف
المناسبه فان
المقاومه تضع دراسه هذا الموضوع في جدول
اعمالها اي اطلاق
سراحهم لذلك المقاومه ووفقا للقيم
الانسانيه
والاسلاميه في موضوع الاسرى المدنيين وغير
اسرائيليين فتتخذ قرارات حكيمه لاعود الى
الدبلوماسيه هل نفهم سيد الوزير بان فشل
الدبلوماسيه سيؤدي بالضروره الى توسع
الجبهات ابلا
حنو
هناك لم يكن حتى الان مشروع سياسي مقبول
من جميع الاطراف ولا يوجد هذا المشروع
حاليا على الطاوله
لانه سبب ذلك يعود الى ان طرف الامريكي
يقف الى جانب
اسرائيل وحاليا يرى الحل في قتل النساء
والاطفال
والمدنيين واثاره الرعب في غزه لكن تصورهم
هو خاطئ ان قاده المقامه الفلسطينيه اكدوا
في اللقاءات معي
بانه نحن ولفتره طويله لدينا الامكانيات
والطاقات العاليه للرد على الكيان
الصهيوني وخلال حديث مع الاطراف السياسيه
المختلفه في المنطقه فالجميع يعتقد
بانه يجب ان يكون هنا ملف وحزمه
كامله المقابل وهذا الملف ياتي من اجل
حيلوله دون تساع نطاق الحرب
و وقف جرائم الحرب للكيان الصهيوني ضد
المدنيين وارسال المساعدات
الانسانيه
والعاجله حل وحل مشكله قطع المياه
والكهرباء وعدم ارسال الادويه والطعام
وايضا فتح
المعبر من اجل نقل المصابين يجب ان يقوموا
بكل ذلك وفي والا ستتوسع الجبهات اذا لم
تفعل اسرائيل هذا
وفي هذه
الحزمه وخلال مباحثات السس توجد هذه
الفكره بانه قضيه الاسرى ايضا من الممكن
ان تكون في جدول الاعمال لكن في في حال
استمرار الوضع الراهن فان اتساع نطاق
الحرب هو امر لا يمكن اجتنابه من قبل
المقاومه في باقي الجبها هذا تحير ما هي
الخطوط الحمراء بالنسبه لايران في هذه
الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه وع حماس
تحديدا والفصائل
الفلسطينيه خو ان الخطوط الحمراء بالتاكيد
لا يعلنها اي
طرف لكن
هناك من الممكن ان تحدث اي احتماليه في
حال الوضع
الراهن ان حزب الله
قد حدد جميع مراحل للخطوط الحمراء وفي كل
مرحله سيتخذ الاجراءات
المناسبه وان باقي فصائل المقاومه التي لم
تدخل حتى الان الى هذا الصراع فكلهم لديهم
السيناريوهات الخاصه بهم وحددوا هذه
السيناريوهات نحن نستمر بدعمنا السياسي
والدولي والاعلامي القوي للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه
ونحذر توقف بانه وقف جرائم الحرب ضد
الابرياء في غزه والنساء والاطفال في
غزه ان ان ان ان يكونوا حذرين بشان هذا
الموضوع قبل ان يتاخر الاوان سالتكم عن
الخطوط الحمراء لايران اعطيتني الخطوط
الحمراء بالنسبه لحزب الله هل هذا يعني
بان في حال فشل الدبلوماسيه الرد اان
سيكون حصرا عبر حزب الله وجبهه جنوب لبنان
ضد اسرائيل سي
الوزير نونم انا لا استطيع ان ادخل في
تفاصيل خطط المقاومه المقاومه هي
ستقرر ان حزب الله هو وبتناسب
مع الظروف
والوضع والقرارات التي تتخذ التي يجب ان
تتخذ في اي لحظه ستتخذ ايضا الاجراءات
المناسبه نحن
ابدا لا لا
نامر اصدقائنا وحلفائنا هم بالتاكيد
يتخذون القرار وهم يقدمون على الاجراءات
كما ان حماس هي قررت وهي
نفذت
واظهرت انه هذا الان الصهيون المزيف اظهرت
صورته الحقيقيه للعالم اجمع ان جرائم
الكيان الصهيوني في
عبور از حد و مرضها حال تذهب نحو اجتز
الحدود المتعارف
عل قبل
لت ان احد قاده المقاومه اكد لي
بانه احد المشافي الخاصه بالاطفال قد تم
استهدافها بقنابل فسفوريه للكيان الصهيوني
القاتل الاطفال هذه الجرائم من
شانها ان ترسم الخطوط الحمراء لباقي
الفاعلين انني احذر بان قتل الاطفال
والنساء والمدنيين يجب ان يتوقف
فورا واذا انتم تريدون الحرب فيجب ان
تحاربوا العسكريين ولا النساء والاطفال
بمعلوماتكم الاستخباراتيه وتواصلكم مع
فصائل المقاومه في قطاع غزه هل تستعد
اسرائيل لعمليه اجتياح بري وذا لو حصل
هذا بهذا الخصوص ان قاده المقاومه يجب ان
يبدو وجهات نظرها لكن في الماضي
ايضا قد ارتكبوا مثل هذا الخطا قد ارتكب
الصحين مثل هذا الخطا في الصحين وكان
يفكرون بارتكاب هذا الخطا طبعا انا ومن
خلال تقييم تقييمي ل ما قاله قاده
المقاومه هو انه في في حال ان قرر الكيان
الصهيوني العنصري من
اجل تنفيذ اي هجوم بري في غزه فان كل شيء
لتحويل غزه الى مقبره ومقتل لجميع الجنود
العسكريين فهو جاهز هل الحد الفاصل
بالنسبه لكم هو بدء اسرائيل عمليه عسكريه
للقضاء على حماس كما يقول نتنياهو هذا
الهدف بالنسبه لاسرائيل
نتنياهو رزها نتنياهو لها امال واحلام
كثيره لكن بخصوص نتنياهو هناك حدث امر ما
انه يوم السبت الماضي في السابع من اكتوبر
فان نتنياهو وحكومه اسرائيل التزمت
الصمت الان امريكا تسعى من اجل انه تمثال
ودم ان تحافظ على تمثال ودميه اسرائيل في
المنطقه
ثانيا اسرائيل ان اسرائيل حت
اقلال ل قد تراجعت لسنوات
كثيره في وضعها وهذا الوضع المتوتر في
الداخل الكيان الصهيوني والازمات
المتراكمه الازمات السياسيه والاجتماعيه
والامنيه ف كل هذا سيدل على انه تزول
اسرائيل سؤال الاير فقط تعقيب على على هذه
النقطه هل بدا اسرائيل بعمليه عسكريه
سيكون حط فاصل بالنسبه لكم وفصائل
المقاومه وما يعرف ب توحيد
الجبهات هر ساعت
بهرو هر ساعت ساعه
تستمر جرائم الحرب للكيان الصهيوني ضد
النساء والاطفال
زه
ست
احتماله احتماليه لاتساع نطاق
الحرب اكثر واثر ام لكن
الوم يختلف الامر مع قبل اربعه ايام وهو
انه اليوم فان الوضع في غزه وفلسطين
والمنطقه هو يشبه الوضع
وضع وضع مخزن الوقود ومخزن المتفجرات وفي
اي لحظه وفي اي دقيقه من الممكن ان يحدث
هناك انفجار شامل وغير قابل
للسيطره اذا قبل ان يتاخر الاوان فيجب
اتخاذ اي خطوه او اطلاق اي مبادره سياسيه
ويجب ان يكون ذلك في جدول الاعمال ونتيجه
ذلك يجب ان تكون جنايات جن وف جرائم الحرب
ونتيجه ذلك يجب ان يكون التركيز على
مبادره سياسيه او دوليه نحن وبهذا الشان
تحدثنا اليوم مع سمو سمو امير قطر كان
لدينا مباحثات مهمه حول هذا الموضوع
لكن الوقت ينتهي بالحديث عن الحل السياسي
وانت تمثل الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه واختم
بهذا السؤال دول عربيه ودول غ الات
المتحده الامريكيه تتحرك على اساس حل
الدولتين بين فلسطين واسرائيل هل انتم في
في سياق هذا التحرك ايضا حل
الدولتين نحن نعتقد
بانه ان الكيان الصهيوني المصطنع
والمزيف يفهم فقط لغه القوه يفهم فقط لغه
المقاومه هذا اولا وثانيا نحن بشان مبادره
السياس قد
سجلنا مشروعا في الامم المتحده وهو اجراء
استفتاء عام بين جميع السكان الاصليين
لفلسطين وتشمل اليهود والمسيحيين
والمسلمين نحن نعتقد بانه في هذه في هذا
المشروع الديمقراطي فما يختارها السكان
الاصليون
لفلسطين يهان و
مسحان يختاره اليهود والمسلمون والمسيحيون
في
فلسطين الاصليون في فلسطين فنتي هذا
الاستفتاء يحدد مستقبل فلسط بار ر مره
اخرر و صانه خود را به اقدم تحياتي الحاره
ل جميع النساء والاطفال في فلسطين ولا
سيما في غزه و اعلن بكل صراحه باسم
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه واؤكد
بان الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايران لم ولن تتخلى بته عن اطفال ونساء
والمدنيين في فلسطين الذين يعيشون في ظروف
صعبه ولن تنساهم بتاتا ونحن سنستمر في
جميع جهودنا السياسيه والدوليه من اجل
مساعده الشعب الفلسطيني
المظلوم ان
ونحن ارسال المساعدات الانسانيه منها
الطعام والادويه ومياه
الشرب منذ صباح يوم الاحد الماضي فهذه
المساعدات هي جاهزه ونحن نامل بانه بعد
التنسيق الاولي والمبدئي الذي قمنا به مع
معالي وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري فان
مصر تساعدنا بشكل اسرع لفتح معبر لارسال
المساعدات الايرانيه وباقي الدول الم واص
الى دا غزه شكرا جزيلا شكرا لك السيد حسين
امير عبد اللهيان وزير خارجيه الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الايرانيه شكرا شكرا لكم مشاه
الكرام على حسن المتابعه الى اللقاء
والتغطيه مستمره